as prices continue to rise your money is
not going to go as far as it once did of
course joe moeller gives us a look at
what you can now get
for the average price of a home in the
valley
the housing market here in las vegas
continues to boom but what you can get
today versus five or ten years ago looks
a lot different it's a market that
it is continuing to escalate as
temperatures rise in las vegas this
summer so do the housing prices
it's really creating a lot of concern
for
many of the buyers that cannot go above
the four hundred
thousand dollar price range trish nash
is a real estate broker
in june the average price was 395
thousand dollars for a home in the
valley
nash says years ago you could get
something much bigger than what you can
find today five years ago
you could get maybe a 3 000 square foot
home with a pool
for 450 000 what you're getting now
for your dollar is is has really reduced
we took a look at what you may find for
three hundred and ninety five thousand
dollars
in growing north las vegas you can get
more for that price like this five
bedroom two thousand square foot home
in henderson single family homes are
harder to come by at that price
this home is one example it is 500
square feet smaller and 10 years older
it's creating buyers to have to also
look at other options such as
condos condos and townhomes are also
selling for
much more near saint rose parkway an up
and coming area of west henderson
new town homes are now selling for
almost 400 thousand dollars
nash says the demand is high especially
from out-of-state buyers
we jumped on one of the waiting lists
with one of the builders and
we did not get our first choice of model
because the waitlist was just too long
barr and his fiancee are moving to las
vegas from los angeles
they are building a home he says the
market was more hectic than they thought
but still makes more sense than l.a
the process you know five years ago
would have i think been totally
different
i'm definitely sure it was a lot cheaper
than it is now many want to know when
these prices will drop
nash doesn't expect that to happen
anytime soon she says
she expects prices to continue to go up
for some time but eventually
level off reporting in las vegas joe
moeller hit news now
rent price is on the rise as well
according to rent cafe the average price
of a one bedroom in las vegas just shy
of
one thousand two hundred dollars up nine
percent from one year ago